♫ -Musical genre challenge ♫
-Here´s how it works.
We´re going to take turns
hitting this button here,
which activates
the random genre generator.
And it will land on
one random song title
and one random musical genre.
Whoever´s turn it is has to sing
that song in that style.
Okay?
Here´s a microphone for you.
-All right. Thank you.
-Here´s one for me.
I will start us off
to show how it´s done.
Here we go.
Song -- "Cotton Eye Joe."
[ Light laughter ]
Soft rock.
I love --
I know "Cotton Eye Joe."
Do you know the first line of
"Cotton Eye Joe?" Anyone know?
[ Audience shouts ]
It´s not beebadee blobadee.
[ Laughter ]
Very close.
I thought it was beebadee.
It´s "if it hadn´t been for
Cotton Eye Joe,
I´d be married a long --"
It´s good trivia.
All right. Sweet.
Soft rock.
Can we do yacht rock?
Can you give me
like a yacht rock,
like a Michael McDonald
type of vibe?
♫♫
[ Vocalizing ]
♫ If it hadn´t been
for Cotton Eye Joe ♫
♫ I´d be married
a long time ago ♫
♫ Where did you come from,
where did you go ♫
Cotton Eye Joe ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Vocalizes ]
All right, all right.
-That was beautiful.
Most beautiful "Cotton Eye Joe"
I´ve ever heard.
Lot of heart in that.
-It´s your turn.
Go ahead and press the button.
-All right.
"Ignition."
Bluegrass.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Here we go.
-"Ignition."
-All right, let´s do it.
Real hillbilly this time.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♫ It´s the remix to ignition ♫
♫ Hot and fresh
out the kitchen ♫
♫ Mama rollin´ that body,
got every man in here wishin´ ♫
-Whoo-hoo!
♫ -Sippin on a Coke and rum ♫
♫ I´m like, "So what?
I´m drunk" ♫
♫ It´s the freakin´ weekend,
baby ♫
♫ I´m about to
have me some fun ♫
♫ Come on now ♫
♫ Bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce
bounce, bounce, bounce ♫
♫ Bounce, bounce, bounce,
bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce ♫
♫ Come on ♫
♫ Bounce, bounce, bounce,
bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce ♫
Yee-haw!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fantastic! Come on.
That´s how you do it
right there.
-Thank you.
Thank you very much.
-Bluegrass version of
"Ignition."
All right. Here we go.
I will go again,
but I don´t know why.
I´m competing against you.
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh!
-"Santeria."
Latin like a --
like a Julio Iglesias type?
Just give me a note, maybe.
Just give me a note.
♫♫
♫ [ Latin accent ] I don´t
practice santeria ♫
♫ Yo no tengo crystal ball ♫
♫ Well, I had a million pesos
but I´d, I´d spent it all ♫
♫ Santeria, oh, santeria ♫
♫ Oh, I don´t have
a crystal ball ♫
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Beautiful once again.
A lot of heart.
-That was better than
the Michael McDonald one, maybe.
I felt that one.
-Yeah.
How do you get lighting cues?
-I don´t know.
-By the way, when I´m here
tomorrow, lighting cues.
-You need props.
-I´m gonna have
so many lighting cues.
It´s out of control.
-You´re here all week,
so they´ll get to know you.
-All right,
I want a lot of them.
-Here we go.
Take us home with one.
-It´s like when I found out
about pyro on "The Voice."
That was crazy.
"Bodak Yellow."
Pop. All right.
All right.
You guys ready?
-"Bodak Yellow," pop version.
♫♫
♫ -I don´t dance now ♫
♫ I make money moves ♫
♫ Say I don´t gotta dance ♫
♫ If I see you
and I don´t speak ♫
♫ I don´t eff with you ♫
♫ I´m a boss,
you a worker bitch ♫
♫ I make money moves,
money moves ♫
♫ I don´t dance now ♫
♫ I make money moves,
money moves ♫
♫ I don´t gotta dance ♫
♫ I make money moves ♫
♫ If I see you
and I don´t speak ♫
♫ I don´t eff with you ♫
♫ I´m a boss ♫
Can I get a little lighting?
Lighting on me?
♫ I make money moves,
money moves ♫
♫ If I don´t see you,
I don´t eff with you ♫
♫ I´m a boss,
you a worker bitch ♫
♫ I make money moves,
money moves ♫
-That´s all the time we have for
"Musical Genre Challenge."
Give it up for Miley Cyrus!
We have a special musical
performance from Miley
after the break!
♫ -If I don´t speak,
I don´t eff with you ♫
♫ I make money moves,
money moves ♫
♫ Ohhh ♫